why did we lose the technology to go to
the Moon we didn't lose the technology
it just the ones that were these
anti-grab devices
um they never wanted the public to know
the traditional rocket systems and going
there and that put the guy bash on that
after the landing because when we landed
there were other assets there what was
there if you look if you read the
unacknowledged book that goes with the
documentary you'll see there's a
testimony from Carl wolf he was out here
at Langley Air Force Base at a National
Security Agency highly compartment in
operation where he saw in 1968 the early
digital downloads of what was called the
lunar orbiter that was going around the
Moon mapping the moons we'd know where
to land in 1969 and in some of those
images were
ancient
structures
and also there were some newer ones
structures this is 1968. so it's on the
dark side of the moon is this the side
that we don't ever see it was in the
area between where the the where the
light that we see and the dark that area
uh as the moon because the moon spins
but it's just the way it's with us we
always see that one side but my point is
is that uh
when the Sun's shining on anyway it's
just the motion of the Moon and the
Earth and the Sun it was known that it
was likely we were going to have
something like that happen so when we
landed at the Landing site the
Tranquility see the crater above it was
quote unquote crowded with these UFOs
sitting there and I know this for a fact
Buzz Aldrin knows that Neil Armstrong
knew it I tried to get Neil to come Neil
Armstrong to come forward but he told
his one his one of his best friends was
worked with me and he says yes but he's
been told if he ever talks about that he
his wife his kids and his grandchildren
will be killed they'll wipe them out
yeah so I said look I'm not going to
force the issue but I know what happened
when we landed I know what was there you
know how it got covered up how the
signals were intercepted and things
erased from the footage before the
public would see it through a relay
based out of Australia at any rate the
the point I'm making is that yes I mean
so I think at a certain point it was
decided maybe we shouldn't pee going
back so they they after a few more
events
they sort of wound down that Moon
project initially we were going to build
a a base up there and do all kinds of
stuff now keep in mind
it wasn't just extraterrestrial assets
there were man-made assets already on
the moon
from before from from the ancient times
no from this covert group so remember
let me give your folk your listeners a
date October
1954 was the date we mastered what's
called gravity control these
electromagnetic field systems
so one of the things we're going to show
in the Lost century and at the national
Press Club the national Press Club event
in June may happen before the film's out
I the distributor's still trying to fix
a date
but we're going to show that whole film
at the two-day conference before the
Press Club
on that Sunday evening it's going to be
the Washington DC premiere of this but
in it people are going to see the
testimony and the drawings and the and
the uh artist rendition of this Air Show
at Norton Air Force Base in 1988
where uh but we have someone who is in
there who and we have the transcript of
what he just saw and described that he
gave that were three of these man-made
uh circular UFOs I think one was about
25 30 feet one was 50 and one was 100
feet and they were just floating above
in a hangar in a classified area
man-made human made 100 man-made and
those were they know they were man-made
oh it was clear they were being shown as
deep black classified aircraft
I mean that's what it was
um and so
and it was really a pitch to to certain
people uh to get more money for the
project but the man who saw this the
interior the components were from the
Mercury era meaning late 50s early 60s
and it they it had markings on it where
it clearly and they were told it had
been all throughout the solar system so
we're talking late 1950s early 1960s we
had electrograbidic anti-grav objects
that had gone out of the earth and
around the solar system if that
technology existed in the 50s which
seems like when everything started to
happen with interactions with
extraterrestrials and perhaps crafts and
reverse engineering things
did they do it that quick or was it or
is it how long did it take them to
create those okay again this those
unpack that for a minute we unpacked
this in the Lost Century this movie
coming out
if you go all the way back to the late
mid to late 20s with t-towns in brown
and the akowski frost experiment in
England in Germany
there were very high voltage experiments
where when you put very high voltage
um
frequencies around certain crystalline
materials or certain
circuits the darn thing would lift and
this was well documented actually in a
physics journals back then in the late
20s because I call this the Lost Century
it's a whole Century of exotic really
cool science and
um that was being worked on and studied
eventually what was called the B field
b-i-e-f-i-e-l-d b-filled Brown effect
from T Townsend Brown and this other
scientist became a real area of research
now that went forward and then Adolf
Hitler his secret program we had the
atomic bomb he was working on these
electrogravidic man-made sort of
anti-gravity craft that would you know
kick the the stuffing out of our you
know Army Air air force during World War
II but he did not perfect that before
the war ended and so uh Senator John
Warner who is the Republican senator who
passed away last year his son John
Warner IV I met with and we've
interviewed him and he talks about how
his grandfather his mother's father Paul
Mellon one of the few billionaires in
the world at the end of World War II
went over to Germany got this disc now
the words to so-called Nazi Bell this is
an actual disc it was anti-gravity and
uh
Alan Dulles who helped found the CIA and
and Paul Mellon and George S Pat went
over there secured it brought it back to
the United States at the end of World
War II in 1945.
um and then we had Operation Paperclip
where we brought over the most brilliant
Nazi scientists like Werner Von Brown
Herman oberth others now so the research
had been done 20s 30s 40s then got
greatly boosted let's say by the Downing
and study of the Extraterrestrial
vehicles of the 1940s and 50s so you had
two big Rivers combined in terms of
scientific research very black very
classified that then resulted in this
breakthrough where they actually were
able to control accurately what they
call gravity control and one of these
electromagnetic devices what Hitler had
was unstable and actually the early ones
that you see from the late 4 30s and 50s
and some of the old movies you'll see
this UFO and it looks like it's
fluttering like this
that's a that's a man-made one where
they hadn't gotten the control of it
mastered it was unstable yeah it wasn't
a stable uh flight system at that point
but where they got good gravity control
was October 54 by the late 50s we had
the man-made ones unfortunately they've
also been used in simulating ET events
with abductions and other things so the
the public not knowing what I just told
all of you guys are going to see
something like this and go oh the aliens
that I said yeah right
that's what that's one of my uncles
companies classified objects or a
Lockheed Skunk Works object or Raytheon
triangle
okay so now we're to the 60s the three
crafts are on the moon
and we know what I'm just saying these
other craft gone all through the soil
what which ones were up on the moon yeah
I don't have enough information to know
whether those were hours or
extraterrestrial it's quite possible
when we landed on the moon there were
et's who were there because they were
concerned that the Apollo mission was a
proxy for the Cold War and the Soviet
and American competition and I think
there's a policy out there amongst these
Advanced civilizations that you don't go
out into space unless it's in a peaceful
unified purpose you don't do it for
conquest and Military purpose I think
it's a major directive from a from these
civilizations which by the way there are
many many of them it's not just one and
so I think there is a policy not to let
a primitive
um violent civilizations such as ours
too far out there so I cannot tell you
that's us right I personally have not
seen the footage I know people who have
seen the footage
of those objects that were of when we
landed
um but I don't know from the description
I can't tell you if it was one of our
man-made ones or an extraterrestrial
there are certain things you can tell an
extraterrestrial vehicle is seamless
even the light from it is unusual
because it's so pure a man-made one if
you close enough to it it's going to
have seams it's going to have rivets
it's going to have Parts the
interstellar ones do not because of how
they're manufactured which we're also
going to show in the movie we're going
to show actually how they bring from a
trans-dimensional
field of energy into 3D
it's like trans-dimensional 3D printing
but the whole craft is this integrated
seamless object
and so are there suits their suits don't
have buttons and zippers they
materialize on and off I know you know
how that's done and they're very
interesting Technologies so if you know
what to look for sure you're not going
to be fooled but this is such a granular
level of information
um and so for most people who would
encounter a man-made
UFO with Critters that look like aliens
they're going to get tricked you know
yeah sure because we haven't seen any of
it why
terrestrials interested in us
well I think there are two things uh one
they see the great promise of humanity
but they also see that we're in a really
big problem right now so if you look at
the modern era and this is not talked
about often and I won't emphasize this
if you look at the modern era of the UFO
issue it all started really in the 40s
and particularly when we detonated the
first atomic bomb why
Not only was that like a big red flag
going up over the planet saying wow
these gorillas are getting a little
crazy here we're 98 identical to
gorillas and chimpanzees some of us more
than others speaking for myself what
I've learned is that everyone knows what
an electromagnetic pulse is from an
atomic bomb or nuclear bomb what people
don't hear about is that there is
another
electromagnetic burst that goes fast
from the speed of light it's called
longitudinal or scalar and that actually
tears the fabric of the universe and
it's not just localized to Earth it
actually disrupts communication and
let's say trans-dimensional travel
systems that are Interstellar so when
those went off
it was a huge concern and this is why
all through the 40s 50s 60s there was
surveillance by these et's over all of
our missile sites nuclear weapons story
and it wasn't because they're hostile
now the way the media has begun to spun
this and the UFO Kooks is that it's an
alien invasion of our nuclear silos I'm
going get over yourselves if they want
to hit a button and terminate all life
on this planet they could do it
instantly with what they had
technologically it was because our
Sciences have been misused for war and
when you cross the nuclear threshold
never mind Interstellar
trans-dimensional physics which are even
more potentially dangerous
if you haven't become socially and
spiritually a peaceful
Planet living together in peace you are
an existential threat to yourself and to
others if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen